[Música]
la catedral de svetitsjoveli es el
centro religioso más importante de
georgia se sitúa en el lugar donde se
construyó la primera iglesia ortodoxa
del país en el siglo cuarto
sacar esta carta marcolli tristes
partido me lista la túnica de jesucristo
está enterrada aquí
fue traído aquí después de su
crucifixión
antes de que el archimandrita illia se
convirtiera en uno de los miembros más
destacados de la iglesia ortodoxa
georgiana fue agente de los servicios de
seguridad soviéticos llegó a ascender
hasta convertirse en suplente del
ministro del interior en aquella época
los comunistas vigilaban de cerca a la
iglesia
no había nada en la ley que prohibiera a
la iglesia pero los comunistas sabían
que no podían ser vistos rezando
algunos iban a la iglesia en secreto los
nombres de los que eran sorprendidos se
ponían en una lista las personas que
aparecían en esta no conseguían buenos
trabajos algunos incluso fueron
despedidos
estas medidas duraron hasta el final de
la unión soviética hasta los años 90
después
cuando empezamos a luchar por la
independencia las cosas cambiaron
la iglesia tomó la delantera otras
fuerzas políticas luchaban por su apoyo
tras la independencia a la iglesia se
convirtió en la columna vertebral del
floreciente estado georgiano
consolidando su influencia en la
sociedad hoy goza de protección
constitucional no paga impuestos y tiene
voz en la educación del país
[Música]
la religión ocupa un lugar muy
importante en mi vida a esta iglesia en
particular le tengo un cariño especial
vengo aquí desde que tenía cuatro años
el país debería ser libre debería estar
libre de influencias y restricciones
negativas especialmente libre de
cualquier influencia extranjera
casi el 84 de los georgiano se definen
como cristianos ortodoxos muchos sienten
que sus tradiciones se ven amenazadas
por los valores liberales occidentales
ahora que el país se prepara para
solicitar formalmente el ingreso en la
unión europea en 2024 antes de ser
sacerdote el padre david fue un
activista independentista en los años 90
él también estaba preocupado
y
claro que la iglesia apoya la idea de
que georgia se convierte en una
democracia occidental y somos parte de
europa
pero no deberíamos perder nuestra
cultura perder nuestras tradiciones y
sustituirlas por otras
30 años después de la independencia los
valores tradicionales de la iglesia son
cuestionados por una juventud cada vez
más numerosa nacida después de la era
soviética además la iglesia se enfrenta
a escándalos se le acusa de estar detrás
de los actos de violencia que provocaron
la cancelación de una marcha el gbc aquí
en tíflis el 5 de julio
alrededor de 4000 personas fueron
movilizadas por la iglesia y estaban ahí
para rezar frente al parlamento pero
unas 1000 personas eran esta fuerza
física activa que ejecutó la operación
estaban dispersas por toda la ciudad
fue un enorme ataque a la sociedad de
mentalidad liberal de georgia a las
ideas progresistas a los ideales pro
occidentales al camino de la integración
de la unión europea porque ese día la
bandera de la unión europea fue quemada
dos veces
aunque la gran mayoría de los georgia
nos apoya a la candidatura del país a la
unión europea la mayoría también rechaza
las políticas del bloque en relación con
las minorías sexuales
el padre david vive en un suburbio de
estilo soviético a las afueras de tíflis
está casado y tiene cinco hijos
el golf por barril
me lo darían ese tipo
mis hijos tienen fe vale no son muy
practicantes
pero tienen un fuerte vínculo con la
iglesia
si mi papá es un sacerdote pero es mi
papá antes que todo no es solo un
sacerdote como si estuviera en una
especie de burbuja
realmente creo que la iglesia ha sido
atacada violentamente desde diferentes
ángulos
ellos piensan que si son capaces de
hacer cosas malas son libres no no son
libres están controlados por otras
personas por decisiones de otras
personas ideas sobre la libertad
federico entre
la gente de mi edad sólo quiere ser cool
y creer en algo o tener una fe no es
algo muy cool
eso me parece triste
la próxima generación de sacerdotes
ortodoxos georgiano se forma aquí en el
seminario teológico de tíflis
la eucaristía no puede suceder si las
personas no se reúnen y jesucristo se
encarnó como hombre para expiar los
pecados de la humanidad
432 estudiantes asisten a cursos aquí en
estado de grupos sus shows tu euro
causil si la unión europea o quien sea
no se exige que rechacemos el
cristianismo ortodoxo y rechazamos
nuestras tradiciones eso sería
inaceptable para nosotros
completamente inaceptable
independientemente de lo que quieran los
jóvenes seguirá siendo inaceptable
la iglesia no es y voy a decir esa
palabra ahora no es una ong la iglesia
es un cuerpo místico de cristo y los que
luchan contra la iglesia están realmente
luchando contra jesucristo nadie ha
ganado nunca esa batalla y nadie lo hará
16 siglos de batallas le han enseñado a
la iglesia a mantener su terreno
ideológico y a jugar a largo plazo una
estrategia que recientemente la hizo
resurgir tras siete décadas de opresión
soviética
[Música]